[Música]
muy buenos días
antes que nada
quiero decirles lo mucho que los
paraguayos les queremos a costa rica
si hay un país que admiramos si hay un
país que aspiramos a ser es costa rica
para nosotros es un honor ser amigo de
costa rica y para mí un gustazo poder
venir a este país yo he tomado cursos en
encaje en alumnos de nuestra escuela
agrícola han venido y vienen a ers
university tengo grandes amigos
conozco a roberto sasso y a roberto
artavia hace muchos años así que muchas
gracias por la bondad y por la
hospitalidad de este gran país
hace 30 años estoy trabajando en los
programas de apoyo a la microempresa que
es realmente una una gran cosa fíjense
han habido vendedoras de naranjas hace
miles de años hay de doradas de naranja
en las jardines colgantes de babilonia
en las pirámides de egipto ya había una
señora igual que ésta siempre hubo
vendedora ambulante de naranja y hace
como 40 45 años sucedió un milagro
fueron rebautizadas
y alguien dijo no no es una vendedora de
naranjas no
a mí me parece una no es una
microempresaria microempresaria sí y
cuando se le cambió el nombre sucedió el
milagro porque surgió de ella tanta
energía se volvió sujeta de crédito
sujeta de seguros surgió la industria de
las microfinanzas y hoy en día gente que
era despreciada por los economistas y
por los gobiernos
son considerados el pilar de la economía
y hay 250 millones de microempresarias
en el sistema formal de la banca en el
mundo creando nuevos empleos
fortaleciendo sus empleos precarios y
creando fuentes de trabajo
de esta señora depende de la economía de
nuestros países pero no sucedió algo
raro porque en la medida en que le
prestábamos un préstamo de 40 dólares y
lo devolvía y le prestábamos 70 dólares
y nos devolvía y le prestábamos 150 y
500 y nos devolvía iba aumentando sus
ventas e iba ganando más dinero hasta
que mucha gente nos dijo dejó de ser
pobre y entonces ya no le puedes prestar
más entonces nos quedamos esa señora
dejó de ser pobre sí porque ahora ya
gana 500 dólares al mes ella y su marido
una familia de cuatro
papá mamá con dos hijos con 500 dólares
están por encima de la línea de pobreza
que la línea de pobreza es la
herramienta que usan los gobiernos para
decir si la gente es pobre o no es pobre
muy bien pero que no sucede
qué
la hermana la vecina tiene serios
problemas de dientes
esta señora vive en un ambiente
contaminado
no tiene idea de cómo ahorrar nadie
sabes llevar cuentas el dinero que entra
desaparece
tiene terribles baños letrinas un
terrible sistema de salud o respiran
humo cuando cocinan con sus chinas a
leña o viven en casitas como esta que no
sería el problema si es que no vivieran
con un total hacinamiento y cuando no
duermen todos en la misma cama duermen
en papá mamá y los hijos todos en la
misma habitación
entonces la gente humilde
sabe que la pobreza no es solamente
dinero
que la pobreza es multidimensional que
es además de dinero un montón de cosas
me hace estar hoy aquí presentando
después que la brillante presentación
del doctor rafael grossman porque ya
hizo toda mi presentación la tecnología
resulta que todo el mundo tiene un
teléfono
lo impensable todo el mundo tenemos una
computadora de bolsillo
la gente humilde en todo el mundo
también tiene esto
qué tal si utilizamos la tecnología no
solamente para hacer la medicina que
propone el doctor rafael grossman que me
pareció brillante sino que tal si
utilizamos la tecnología para empoderar
a la gente más débil y vulnerable del
mundo para comprender lo que es la
pobreza multidimensional no solamente
ingreso y empleo sino también salud y
medioambiente vivienda infraestructura
educación y cultura lo cual es típico
pero sabemos que también la pobreza es y
no es organización y participación
ciudadana pero después hay un problema
de que la pobreza también tiene que ver
con autoestima violencia contra la mujer
capacidad de resolver conflictos a
espíritu emprendedor
cómo se mide eso
nosotros estamos
proponiendo que la gente misma se
autodiagnóstico utilizando
una sencilla tecnología
tú en cada indicador eres verde amarillo
o rojo
tú en el ahorro familiar eres verde o
amarillo o rojo en 20 minutos cualquier
persona del mundo cualquier
costarricense cualquier brasileño
cualquier nigeriano cualquier indígena
guaraní de paraguay si está bien
formulada la pregunta y la imagen es
correcta en 20 minutos puede definir su
pobreza o no pobreza multidimensional
utilizando un sistema tan fácil como es
el semáforo verde estoy bien amarillo
estoy mal y rojo estoy muy mal y se
pueden nosotros hemos encontrado 50
indicadores en seis dimensiones rojo es
pobre extremo amarillo es pobre y verde
es no pobre por ejemplo
dinero en mi casa ganamos cien dólares
por persona por mes verde
70 y menos de 100 dólares amarillo o
menos de 75 eso es facilísimo y todo el
mundo sabe qué clase de agua hay en mi
casa verdeamarillos agua en mi país se
define imaginen imagínense lo pobre que
es paraguay la casa tiene un grifo de
agua verde
la casa tiene un pozo de agua amarillo
la familia debe buscar agua a más de 100
metros rojo eso es en mi país en algunas
partes del desierto de nigeria tener un
pozo a 100 metros de la casa es ser
verde en agua y en eeuu
sos amarillo en agua si no tienes agua
caliente
cada país sabe lo que es ser no pobre en
ese país y sería muy interesante
analizar el indicador por indicador que
para el pueblo costarricense significa
estar bien estar mal y estar muy mal en
salud en educación en transporte público
en baño cuál es la definición
costarricense
lo bueno de esto es de qué
la tecnología permite que cada familia
no es que tenga una cifra sencillamente
un tablero de control donde la gente sea
autodiagnóstico y diga soy verde en 20
cosas soy amarilla en 15 y soy rojo en
tal cosa porque también es importante no
reducirla a la gente por las cosas que
no tiene
si no contar las bendiciones porque como
dice el dicho si nos cuentas tus
bendiciones no cuentan y entonces
cualquier familia
puede tener su tablero de control
podemos georeferenciar entonces ya no
hay barrios pobres y barrios pobres
porque a lo mejor uno vive en un barrio
lindo pero tiene serios problemas de
peso y otra persona vive en un barrio
humilde y es feliz y no tiene ese
problema es verde no y como decía el
escritor ruso león tolstoi en su novela
anna karenina todas las familias felices
son iguales y cada familia infeliz es
infeliz a su manera cada familia humilde
es humilde a su manera y la tecnología
nos puede permitir rescatar estos otros
que volvemos a esta gente e ir un
poquito más profundo porque no tiene
dientes es por su comportamiento
no se lavan los dientes nunca se cuidó
los dientes o es por el sistema
no hay dentista en el barrio o es por su
cultura es en ese país a esa edad si la
señora no tiene dientes ya no es un
problema o es que ella tiene miedo
y hacer también entender lo que
significa la agencia y la autoeficacia
la gente cambia como diría el psicólogo
albert bandura no por solamente por
premios y castigos la gente cambia
cuando cree que puede cambiar y para
cambiar para arreglar su baño para
aumentar sus ingresos para arreglarse
los dientes para subir de peso para
bajar de peso la gente tiene que
responder sí a dos preguntas vale la
pena y seré yo capaz de hacerlo y así
estamos desarrollando en cada país como
la gente normal de ese país encuentra
soluciones porque en sudáfrica en mexico
en tanzania y en taiwán y en papúa nueva
guinea hay una manera de conseguir
sillas de ruedas hay una manera de
arreglarse los dientes hay una manera de
tener un baño moderno porque conocemos
gente humilde
que él eso es verde no pero tuvo un
problema porque nuestros oficiales de
microcréditos se nos revelaron dijeron
estamos ayudando a todas estas
microempresas a superar la pobreza
multidimensional y nosotros qué
yo ganó dos veces el sueldo mínimo pero
tengo serios problemas de dientes tengo
serios problemas de tal cosa y de tal
cosa entonces hicimos que cada uno de
nuestros funcionarios haga el semáforo y
nos encontramos que había gente no
obstante cobrar dos sueldos mínimos
diría la extrema pobreza
porque tenía estaba manteniendo una
familia de ocho personas
de todas maneras empezamos a difundir
esto y hoy tenemos un programa que se
llama en esa sin pobreza por lo cual los
los funcionarios y los obreros de cada
fábrica de cada compañía hacen su propio
autodiagnóstico identifican sus
fortalezas y sus debilidades y hacen un
plan familiar para salir de la pobreza
recuerdan ustedes el plan nacional de
desarrollo de nuestros países o el plan
municipal de desarrollo se acabó
la tecnología puede hacer el plan
familiar y me decía un amigo brasileño
famoso activista asociado el senador
cristóvam buarque pero tú creíste
conseguir un loco como cree este
portugués en
como se cree que el gobierno de brasil
va a manejar 40 millones de planes
familiares no el gobierno de brasil no
manejar 40 millones de planes 40
millones de familias brasileñas van a
tener su propio plan pero voy a estar
loco la gente de brasil no está
preparada por supuesto que estás
preparada si todo el mundo tiene su
teléfono su página de facebook se
comunica por whatsapp si se hace bien la
pregunta cualquier persona puede diseñar
su propio plan de desarrollo
estamos trabajando en ya más de 35
países
esta es una empresa y ustedes ver como
entre el 2014 y el 2016
los verdes avanzan y en una fábrica poco
a poco se va superando la pobreza
estamos haciendo análisis estadísticos
que dicen que con el semáforo se sale
tres veces más rápidos de la pobreza que
en una situación normal y la pregunta
que les digo y que les dejo hoy
para salir adelante tenemos que darle a
la gente cada vez más cosas o tenemos
que ser como la lámpara de aladino
aprender a fortalecer empoderar y
concientizar para que la energía salga
de adentro de cada familia para que la
familia esté donde quiera estar
muchas gracias costa rica
[Aplausos]
i
tú
[Música]